all right so a lot of new trailers are
coming out we just got the Dark Knight
Rises now I got another one the newest
trailer I have to talk about it's for
the amazing spider-man is actually
called the amazing spider-man which is
it's a curative it's a little weird I
like spider-man it's cleaner yes they're
rebooting the spider-man story with a
brand new franchise and one of the first
things I noticed in this trailers really
interesting to me because it shows Peter
Parker's parents as soon as your aunt
and uncle for the well but you did have
the right idea if you're gonna leave
your son in the hands of someone let it
be the father of a warlock winning and
they have Gwen Stacy in this one which
means they're going in chronological
order this time and Mary Jane everyone
knows Mary Jane but she wasn't the first
one before Mary Jane there was Gwen
Stacy everyone forgets the blondes and
then you know stuff that you already
know spider bites him pulls like a
spiderweb from the back of his neck
which is that like a web sack or
something it can't be because there are
web shooters in this movie which a web
stack on the back here next oh that
would be really helpful
god forbid you ever go to prison you can
drop the soap if you want you got a web
shooter on the back of your neck keep
you safe let him try and then you get
one glimpse of the villain dr. Connors
he's going to be the lizard and then
he's gone and then after that the part
that everyone's talking about the 3d
spider-man action segment aka the
Mirror's Edge trailer I'm not gonna lie
when I saw this I was like that looks
just like that one game I never play it
dude you got a review Mirror's Edge what
at first I was like this looks like a
video game why are they doing this if
it's not Mirror's Edge then it's that
one first-person segment in the movie
Doom which was the best part of that
movie but that doesn't mean they should
do it in the spider-man movie then I
remember the movies in 3d which means
the trailers in 3d when you see this
trailer in the movie theater in 3d it's
going to look really cool if people
don't get vertigo and throw up because
of this it's just never happening and
there is a part of me that's like oh
that's really cool so this is how
spider-man sees the world that's
actually not a bad way to see it that's
awesome if they do it like once it'd be
alright if they do it alive it'll get
annoying and then the last line comes up
we all have
the ones we keep
and the ones that are kept from us
between that line and the trailers
showing his parents and them cryptically
going other something we got to do then
he finds this old man purse where Uncle
Ben aka the warlocks dad's life got a
little bout that thing was your dad's it
makes me think that Peter Parker's
parents are gonna be a part of the plot
the reason this is interesting is
because in the comic books Peter
Parker's parents were tied in with
shield yeah as in like chilled and since
the Avengers movies coming out in the
same summer I just wonder are they going
to do something with shield are they
gonna mention shield are they going to
mention the Avengers Sigyn I mentioned
samuel l.jackson with an eyepatch I mean
that'd be really cool I'm not expecting
a full-blown tying because Sony's doing
spider-man they didn't do any of the
other like Avengers movie or Avengers
movie tie-ins or anything like that like
a mention would be pretty cool so in the
end I think Andrew Garfield looks really
good as Peter Parker I think he's going
to make a really good spider-man I like
the tone of this movie because the old
spider-man movies I liked him when they
came out but if you watch spider-man 1
now it's a little camping it just is
just the whole thing's really light and
really cheesy I understand spider-man's
like kind of light-hearted but I like
the tone of the new one I want to see
that so I put a link to the trailer
below go check it out come back here
comment below let me know what you think
what do you think of Andrew Garfield how
do you think he's going to do as Peter
Parker and spider-man do you want to see
the whole shield thing in this movie if
you still don't believe me about the
Mirror's Edge thing here you go
we all have secrets
you can't help but think of it really
and if you'd like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]